on tick tock there is a dog named noodle
now each day noodle either wakes up with
bones as seen here where he has enough
strength to stand
or with no bones where he flops back
down onto the bed
noodle has become kind of a guiding
force for the daily mood of the internet
on a bones day people are encouraged to
get out of bed and make the most of
their day maybe take a risk or try
something new whereas a no bones day
might be the time to take it easy and
think a little bit about self-care so
what does this have to do with quantum
computing well almost nothing but i did
notice that the chance of a bones to a
no bone stay does seem to be about 50
50. that's the same chance that a cubit
in a even superposition of states 0 and
1 would have of being measured in either
state i recently found out that quantum
computing is actually further ahead than
where i thought it was and in fact right
now anyone can submit code to be run on
a real quantum computer so to figure out
how to do that i set out to ask a real
quantum computer bones or no bones
the answer might come from some point of
deep intrinsic truth about our universe
or maybe it's just pretty close to truly
random
this video is sponsored by kiskit which
is ibm's open source quantum computing
software with kiskit we can use the
python coding language to actually
program circuits and algorithms for a
quantum computer ibm also give access to
the hardware having already built quite
a few quantum computers these are
currently only relatively small and used
for experimental purposes ibm recently
unveiled their largest one to have
127 qubits but we're still away off from
these quantum systems being large enough
to outperform the classical computers
ibm have made their smaller five qubit
quantum computers free for anyone to use
you just have to submit your code
through the ibm quantum lab but before i
could run my little experiment i first
had to learn just enough about qubits
quantum circuits and programming with
kisket to actually write my program and
i'll quickly fill you in on what i've
learned
all right so it's important to know what
we're dealing with here
in classical computing information is
stored using bits
and these can either be zero or one
they're binary and they're like tiny
little switches
now bits all act independently of each
other
and we can manipulate bits using logic
gates there are quite a few different
kinds of logic gates but for example
one of them is the not gate the not gate
can be drawn
like this
and it would turn a zero into a one or a
one into a zero
now when we're dealing with quantum
computing we're dealing with something
called the qubit and these are just
quantum bits
we can represent cubits as an arrow
pointing on the surface of a sphere
let's see if i can draw a sphere in here
i'll actually draw
a couple
all right so if we have
say an arrow pointing on our sphere and
if that arrow is pointing straight up
well that qubit would be in the zero
state and if the arrow was pointing
straight down
then that qubit would be in the one
state but the arrow can also point
anywhere else on the sphere
our arrow could point to the side like
this
and this qubit is in a superposition of
the zero and one states
now when you measure a qubit you do
still only get out a zero or a one as
the result and that's because
measurement collapses the superposition
if you were to keep measuring the same
qubit again and again you would get the
same result
it is only before measurement takes
place that a qubit is able to exist in
multiple states at once which gives it
the ability to do things that classical
bits can't
that means if you've got a program
that's working with qubits you'll try to
keep measurement to the last step in the
process
if we were to measure this superposition
here we would find that because the
arrow is pointing halfway between the
zero and one that there would be a 50
chance of returning a zero upon
measurement and a fifty percent chance
of getting a one
if instead the arrow had been pointing
maybe more towards the zero that might
have given an eighty percent chance of a
zero twenty percent chance of one and
likewise down here this arrow might have
given eighty percent chance for one
twenty percent chance of a zero
but physically how do you make a cubit
well there are actually several types
it's just any two-state quantum system
such as the spin of an electron or the
polarization of a single photon
ibm uses superconducting transmon cubits
which are a superconducting material on
a silicon chip
arranged so that there is an artificial
atom with quantized energy levels
and then kept extremely cold in a ground
state of zero
radiation can be applied to excite the
qubit to the one state or to enter a
superposition
i spent some time on the kisket online
textbook learning the absolute basics
and i'm pretty happy that i've managed
to get some working code i've just
written it on the ibm quantum lab server
so you don't even need to download
anything if you don't want to
my code starts with importing everything
we need and then i also got it to print
a list of the available hardware that i
can run the code on
it lists the five qubit quantum
computers i can use as well as some
simulators which make more sense when
you're just testing the code
this little code here is setting up my
circuit it's actually fairly simple and
there's a diagram here of what's going
on
q is my one qubit and all qubits start
initialized at 0 which is their ground
state but i want it to be in a 50 50
superposition so i've applied a quantum
logic gate that is the h symbol here it
is the adamar gate
now when it comes to quantum logic gates
there are some that are similar to their
classical counterparts for example there
is a quantum not gate and it's
represented as an x
like the classical not gate that we
looked at
this one has the ability to turn a zero
into a one or a one into a zero it
essentially flips the sign
and we can even see how this is
represented physically with our sphere
if inside our sphere we set up some axes
so
maybe a y there
an x
and up and down to be z
then you can actually see where the
quantum number gate gets its symbol the
x from it actually flips the arrow over
the x axis
so if we had a qubit that was say a zero
meaning that the arrow was pointing
straight up
then if it was to be flipped across the
x-axis
it would come out
looking
like a one
likewise there are some quantum logic
gates called y and z that flip it over
those axes too
but the h gate that we want to use in
our circuit is kind of unique to the
quantum world
after passing through an h gate a qubit
that started as zero will have a fifty
percent chance of being zero and a fifty
percent chance of being one
but the h gate isn't just a randomizer
for example if you were to pass a qubit
through two h gates one after the other
it would basically undo the effect and
you would get back whatever value you
started with
and that's not behavior you would expect
from something that's just randomizing
the results something else is going on
here
what the h gate is actually doing is
applying a rotation around the line
between the x
and the z axes so this line in here
now you might be able to see that if an
arrow had been pointing straight up
representing zero then flipping it over
this line
would put it here
halfway between zero and one meaning it
has fifty percent chance of being
measured as zero and fifty percent
chance of being measured as one
then if you were here and you did
another rotation back around the same
axis so you've applied your second age
gate
well you would actually end up back
where you started back at zero and so
you can see why two h gates do undo the
effect
the last component in my circuit is a
measurement to collapse the
superposition
i'm first going to run the code on the
simulator i've set shots equal to one
which means we're going to run this one
time and we'll get one result out of our
qubit it'll either be a zero and in that
case it'll be a no bone stay or we'll
get a one which will be a bones day
so running this now it prints out that
the result 1 was obtained one time and
that makes it a bones day
running it again we see that 0 was now
returned as the result but let's
increase the number of shots so that we
have more than one result i can increase
it to a hundred
this time it says that the result one
was returned 45 times and 0 was returned
55 times so we're getting close to a 50
50 split but we're not quite there yet
and just to see what happens let's go
for a hundred thousand shots all right
getting even closer to 50 50 here i
think we can be pretty confident that
this code is getting us into that
superposition that we want now i think
we're ready to run it on the real
quantum computer
we can come on to the quantum lab
dashboard and see all of the quantum
computers and whether they're online and
what their queues look like we will need
to join the end of the queue for
whatever job we want to run so hopefully
we can find something where the queue is
pretty short these are actually their
large machines the 127 cubit one up
there in washington but we're going to
want to use the smaller five qubit
machines in fact what we're doing only
needs one qubit really looking here the
machine in pagoda has the smallest queue
with only seven pending jobs so we'll do
is we'll copy that name
take it to our code and tell it that
that's the back end we wish to use
let's just do it with one shot because
we want to find out what kind of day
we're going to have
and if we run this it will send it off
to the quantum computer i can check up
on it in this tab here which are all the
jobs that i've sent
says an estimated time of two minutes
till completion but for you after the
edit that might be a lot shorter
and we've got our result it's a bones
day
it took 2 minutes and 21 seconds to get
the result you can see here it says that
a 1 was measured with 100 probability
and my code returned that it is a bones
day that's wonderful news for all do
something amazing go learn quantum
computing maybe work on that side
project or write some new year's eve
resolutions just so you know whenever
this video reaches you is when your
bones day applies so even if you're
watching this in the future it applies
to you too
we can send another request off with
more shots maybe try 10 000 this time
just to check our distributions
when running things on these real
quantum computers noise is also
something that you usually have to take
into account i think for us since this
is so simple and just with one cubit
doesn't really apply but more
complicated programs would really have
to consider noise in their results
our result is in in six minutes 39
seconds to say that 0 was returned 53 of
the time 1 46 of the time
mine is a pretty trivial use but there
are lots more of those more complicated
algorithms on kisket that you can use
and that actually take advantage of the
quantum abilities for me this is just a
really cool way to learn but it can also
be practical if you're actually wanting
a career somewhere in quantum computing
here is a current active job listing
from ibm quantum it's for a kisket
researcher you can see some of the
responsibilities here it may be no
surprise to see that in required
experience they want you to have done
some research projects already using
kiskit they also want you to have
working knowledge of quantum computing
and at least a master's degree
if working on quantum computers in this
kind of way is something you think you'd
like to do then learning something like
kiskit is really going to help you get
there make the most of your bones day
maybe commit to learning a skill like
this or applying for a new job thanks
for watching this video and thanks to my
patreon supporters a special thanks to
today's patreon cats of the day stinky
and sprinkles
[Music]
you